come to everyone's today's today's
meeting of cabinet those are
participating and those who are watching
on the live stream
as always if members have technical
difficulties during the meeting please
contact the democratic services officer
on call who will attempt to assist you
today that's nick hughes his number is
577208
and it will also be at the top of the
chat thread for members if you need it
for those of you who are watching by the
council's youtube stream please follow
the instructions below the video
if there are any issues with the live
feed and i apologize advance if i in
advance if i have any internet problems
because i've had one to see this
afternoon but hopefully we'll be able to
get through this meeting without that
um i'd ask participants when you're not
speaking please mutual microphone to
minimize background noise
and they'll help everyone else in
listening to the proceedings microphones
must only be on
if the participant has been granted
permission to speak to gain
my permission to speak please very
briefly indicate on the chat to the
right of the screen
and i'll make a note and go back to you
once the person speaking is finished
please note we'll be following the usual
cabinet protocols in which other members
of the council
usually only speak once on each item
would everyone please ensure their
mobile phones are turned to silent and
they're not used to make or receive
phone calls while the meeting is in
progress please also refrain from
checking emails or conducting other
business
and ensure you're in a quiet room free
from distractions for the duration of
the meeting
please note the meeting is being live
streamed for members of the public the
meeting will also be recorded
and subsequently broadcast on the
internet can i ask members of cabinet to
confirm that they are present in the
meeting when i
read out their name and i'll then go on
to those counselors who are
participating to speak under
procedural 20.1 councillor whitehead
present counselor album yeah here
that's the duckworth present councillor
yates
present thank you the following members
have asked to speak under procedural
20.1
when i say your name can you please
confirm your present in the meeting for
item four i've got councillor wing
are you with us councillor
not at the moment uh and for item six
i've got councillor ghana
i'm here chair thank you are there any
other councils that we
just wish to speak under 20.1 councillor
ashby
thank you chair um i'd like to speak
under item four please
item four thank you very much okay made
a note of that
thank you uh there are no apologies for
absence because kevin is all here
does anyone have an interest to declare
in the items of business on the agenda
this evening
i'm not hearing any so i think we could
say you assume that there isn't
any interest to declare minutes to the
previous meeting
uh to improve the summary of
recommendations and decisions at the
cabinet meeting have on the 28th of
january
um i'll propose the minutes do i have a
second to place
i'll be the second expected by
councillor yates
unless i hear any objection i'll take
these as approved
so they're approved thank you and we
move on to item four which is coastal
and
beach public spaces protection order and
that's councillor album
right thank you chair
creating a new public space protection
order
which i will refer to as a pspo
will help our coastline by providing us
with the power to deal with anti-social
behavior
on our beaches we are also introducing
uh one code of conduct
that replaces all the previous beach
bylaws
to complement this the implementation of
the new pspo
will help create a safer beach
environment
for all to enjoy through deterring
and reducing crime and anti-social
behavior
and other undesirable activities
which our local communities and visitors
are
impacted by currently
the pspo focus is on education
and changing behavior then enforcement
where needed we will have more
enforcement presence
than in recent years refocusing
resources
has enabled us to have
to have a dedicated coast enforcement
officer
recruited for the season who will cover
all weekends and peak times
other officers within the team will also
be trained
on the new rules and will have the power
to enforce where necessary
warden patrols will help with the
following as well
making the rules of our coast clear
telling people what we expect of them
and challenging behaviour
being present and visible as a deterrent
we have brought in new rules and
operational changes
that mean tighter controls around our
coast
for people using personnel
powered sorry person personnel personal
powered watercraft
stroke jet skis in an unsafe and
antisocial manner
not to mention the ability to find them
using
the pspo we have taken on board
members comments from overview and
scrutiny
members briefings and the consultation
feedback from the public
and made clarifications and changes
i know members are concerned about the
use of jet skis
as are members of the public so
i have asked jasmine vickers
to show a few slides to show
how these will be specifically dealt
with
and i would ask you to do that now
before i make any
proposal chair
thank you councillor
okay thank you councillor but i'm just
going to
share my screen hopefully everyone can
see this
now
okay and so i'm going to skip the
introduction since council auburn has
has covered that and i'm going to go
straight on to the
jet skis and and personal powered
watercraft
subjects i just wanted to give some
clarifications on this because
through the consultation we have had a
number of
questions and queries raised about this
so this is to hopefully clarify
some of those so the the original
proposal was to remove
all the public launch sites and remove
jet skis entirely from our water user
group
this left three local clubs
so that left jet ski world in
cliftonville beresford club in
birchington
and four nest which is also in
cliftonville but has further
restrictions on on membership there
so you can only join forness club if you
have a boat membership for example
however membership of these clubs does
come with restrictions and they're not
open seven days a week
so the feedback from the consultation
was actually is a bit unreasonable for
jet skiers
who behave responsibly who have the
appropriate training qualifications
um and are respectful of other beach
users
and and bathers to not allow them
anywhere to launch in our district
unless they join one of those clubs
um and then there's no guarantee that
they would be able to
launch on particular days if the clubs
are very busy um
bearers for club also aren't taking on
new members so there's a there's a few
reasons why
actually it was felt that there wouldn't
be a proportionate offering for the
responsible jet skiers
so in light of this and taking this on
board what we are proposing
is a slight amendment which is that to
move ahead with the closure of the
margate launch site
as originally proposed but leave the
ramsgate east cliff launch site as it is
and review it again at the end of this
season and if we feel that there's
you know lots of anti-social uh activity
in relation to jesus he's there
then we could still remove that site
moving forward
we will still be introducing the new
rules
across all pwc use as follows
so all pwc users will need to have the
proficiency qualification which is a
one-off one-day course costing around
160 pounds
so for club users we're giving a grace
period for that
so we're saying that's desirable for
this year because the clubs have a lot
more control over their members anyway
but
um that will enable them to catch up
following the sort of post-covid
um shutdown and a backlog
around those training courses however
for anyone using the ramsgate eastcliff
site we're saying that they would have
to have that qualification
they're not to remove silences from
their machines or carry out any other
modifications to the exhaust system
they must display the unique
registration number on their
um on their machine be over the age of
17
same as if they were driving a car and
on launching
they must make sure to stay away from
the beaches and bathing waters other
coast users are nature reserves around
the coast
and they must not disturb any coastal
wildlife by getting too close
so each of the clubs has its own map on
site which
informs members of the very
site-specific
rules around their launching
so for jet skis pwcs
on signing up to the water user group
they are also agreeing
to a set of rules and regulations and
any breach of those rules and
regulations will mean that their
membership gets terminated and there
will be no refund
they will also potentially face the same
financial penalty as any breach of our
rules
as that would incur under the pspo if
they're found to be
engaging in anti-social activity
so example of breaches
that the penalties would apply to
include the copying of issued barrier
keys
leaving barriers open for non-group
members to access
launching of craft that's not permitted
at a particular site
and those three things um on the face of
it maybe don't sound to be
um very serious but actually what they
do is they allow people who have not got
the appropriate training
or insurance to launch at our site and
it's a safety
issue the use of craft in a manner that
poses a risk to the safety of people or
wildlife
the use of craft in a manner that has
the potential to cause harassment alarm
or distress to any other beach
or coast users or residents
and the main difference that we have now
is that we will have the power under the
pspo to find people for irresponsible
jet ski usage
and that's something that we have never
had before
the water user group just a few changes
to this that need to be highlighted but
these are also measures that will help
with control
of anti-social um jet ski use
and other anti-social behavior with with
watercraft so all the keys and padlocks
are going to be replaced on the 1st of
june
or water user group members will need to
reapply for their membership
they will have to provide proof of
insurance qualifications and payment
before a new key will be issued
the ramsgate east cliff site as i've
mentioned for jet skis will have its own
padlock and key
and that is a measure to stop
powered watercraft accessing any other
launch site around the district so we
have a better control over
um restricting exactly where they launch
from to that one place
where the controls and safety measures
are in place
and then also just an aside to this is
that the ramsgate western undercliff
slipway will be permanently closed and
blocked off
so in retaining the ramsgate east cliff
slipway
um as we've said that they will have to
have membership as part of the council's
water user group
provide proof of qualification insurance
and other details
on launching here you must only turn
left not right making sure to stay away
from the main sands bathing waters
the harbour and the pegal bay national
nature reserve and other wildlife around
the coast
and they must have a proficiency
qualification
um i'm just gonna move
on so another thing just to mention
about ramsgate main stands is that we
have been in discussion with the rnli
and we are looking at having the bathing
water area void off
and that is just another additional
safety measure
so clubs where jet skis will be
permitted bearers for gap in batchington
uh jet ski world at palm bay hodges gap
and forness club also offer a jet ski
membership but only for people with an
existing boat membership
so that is just an overview of the um
jet skis and i'm happy to take any
additional questions on that
at the appropriate time
thank you for that we go back to
councillor album yes
thank you jasmine um and hopefully
that's been uh
that's been of great interest to members
um
so chair um i propose cabinet approve
option 616.1 of the report
thank you thank you counselor album i'm
i'm happy to second that
um and i've got councillor wing uh we we
don't worry about being late counselor
when we are we noticed you'd arrive
thank you that i do i speak now is that
okay
yes please i mean generally speaking i
think this is this is a really positive
move actually
the key to it is obviously going to be
enforcement uh
i still have some concerns about the jet
skis but i'll get to that because there
were
just one or two other things i needed
sort of clarification on uh we
the the we're going to lose a worker
from the foreshores
team so what what will we lose by having
this additional worker
uh it's also going to cost us 5k from
the foreshore's budget so what are we
losing from that budget i understand
that budget is quite
small can we have some clarification on
point
four so we presently have some fitness
groups
working on our beaches will they have to
fill in forms
and the 0.7 actually relates to
events on the beach are particularly
music so if i go down to the beach with
my guitar and
play badly for a group of friends am i
going to be
issued with a hundred pound fine so
there needs to be maybe some greater
clarification on what constitutes
uh an event on the beach uh
you know a group of friends just going
down and somebody playing a guitar
it doesn't constitute an event it
constitutes as reasonable
beach users uh that was point seven
uh point three three says we're gonna
have coastal wardens how many coastal
wardens will we have and i'm making the
assumption that we'll increase that in
this
in the in the summer months when when
the beach is used even more
i'm glad to see the rams gate main sands
is going to be heavily monitored so i'm
assuming
assuming the wardens will spend quite a
lot of time there i think keon there
will be
a signage for locals to report any
illegal use there so
direct communication with the wardens to
pick up anybody who might attempt to cut
locks off because we know that's
happened
i'm glad i would i would also like to
see some channel markers going out
so that so that the the jet skis have a
clear vision of they need to go straight
out to the coast and then turn
left um great to hear that the boys are
going in to protect the the sea bathers
annex two actually mentions ramsgate
harbour and it wasn't quite clear
whether the jet skis can launch from
there or not
if they do how they will have to of
that they can go right or left or
straight out across to france i suppose
if they go left we've got the same issue
as we would have
with the with the with the uh the east
cliff
uh launch site where you've told them to
go left
uh again maybe there needs to be some
sort of guidance that they need to go
further out to avoid those swimming bays
because they will be going across the
main sands there so that could be a
little bit of an issue there
i think you answered jasmine you
answered most of my other questions so
generally speaking i think it's really
positive you're clearly sending a
message that they need to stay away from
from the the our protected areas and our
beaches
i do think the sam's report which i read
is a really really thorough report and
that mentions wardens for enforcement
wardens for education and signage
as the main areas interestingly enough
nowhere in that document is mentioned
jet ski so i really do think that maybe
at this time next year we should be
looking to update that sam's report
based on
what comes out of the change to the the
coastal use and the enforcement
that that document is a really thorough
document that that highlights the
the various impacts on our coast but
also the mitigations that need to be in
place but but well done because i think
you've actually listened
to residents concerns particularly over
the jet skis so
uh i fully support it thank you
thank you council wing um councillor
album did you want to come back on
anything there
yeah i mean i can i can answer some of
them uh councillor wing and
um i'll ask jasmine so well some of the
more technical
things if you like signage will will be
put up
and we've already agreed that um so we
want to ensure
that both the public and water users
know exactly
um what they can do and what that and
what they can't do
you're quite right in relation to you to
use to the beach if you go down
where the guitar and i'd like to see
that um if you go down there with one
and uh want to sing along to your
friends they're singing i'd see
shanty or two um then um
yeah you wouldn't need you won't be
fined you won't be thrown off you won't
be handcuffed and dragged along the
beach
i i can assure you of that um what we
would be looking at is when there is
uh if there is um
an event of some kind which would
obviously need our would need tdc
consent and probably a license of
some kind or if there is any business
activity taking
taking place on the beach that that
would also
um require um a license from us and
and also to gain our authority and there
would be a charge
and why would we not do that um
jasmine if you've got the other
thank you yeah i'm happy to answer the
rest of those
um so the officer um i won't bore
everyone with the details but the
funding for the officer it's not a loss
from the foreshore team
it's as a result of people um
restricting their hours down to
part-time people have changed their
working patterns has created some
savings with the enforcement team and
that's enabled us to create the seasonal
post
um and that there is an opportunity to
potentially make it
um all year round but we want to sort of
see how this works over the summer
period and pilot it as a seasonal
officer for now
um and then we can amend it at the end
of the summer and do other things with
it potentially um
the five thousand pounds for for signage
which is which is in the report
um that has come from the four shores
budget there were some some small
savings made from across various
different pots
um in the last financial year as a
result of the the pandemic and things
perhaps not being
um delivered or some small savings being
made
but that's enabled us to pay for the
signage
um for the pspo the fitness groups i
think as councillor
alban has said and the music and the
events the spirit of the public spaces
protection order is that
um is very heavily around education and
informing and giving people the chance
to change their behavior
challenging the anti-social behavior we
wouldn't stop somebody playing the
guitar
who actually you know wasn't really
causing any any major incident on the
beach
um a lot of it is down to perception and
other residents and beach users
perception so if they felt that that
person was creating
a nuisance or was harassing them or
causing them
alarm in any way um through the music
then arguably there's a potential
to use the pspo but as enforcement
officers we would be looking at
that being proportionate so um it's all
in relation
to that um there has to be an element of
anti-social behavior to most of the
things that are in it
um i think the sam's report that's a
very good point i think it probably will
need a review
and there's a lot going on around
pigworld bay at the moment so there's
definitely some things to be looked at
um and and lots of elements that need to
be considered in that moving forward
um ramsgate harbour we haven't mentioned
it we haven't highlighted it because
we're not really promoting the use of
launching of jet skis from there at the
moment jet skis have always been
able to launch from there technically um
mike may um i'm not sure if mike mike
comes on the meeting tonight but
i know there are plans moving forward
potentially for jet skis and in the
harbour but
um it is something that people can do um
i think we just need to be clear about
again the
the very specifics of the launching at
that site for people that are launching
there
but it's very much controlled through
the harbour office so that they would
they would go in there and pay their day
rate and be given the instructions
at the point of of going to launch um
in terms of the coastal wardens we have
bid for some
some external money to to fund this our
intention is to have
four of them continuing throughout the
summer period
but um they would be i think as you
picked up
not an enforcement officer so not um
having delegated power to issue tickets
but they would be focusing on the
education
the information the challenging of
behaviors so they would be performing
that function
we've also been for some money to double
the number of those which i'm hoping
that we'll be successful in
um and then therefore we would have
plenty of them to be able to spread out
around the district to do those really
proactive patrols
and then within the existing enforcement
team we're um
giving the officers that already exist
the training
and the seasonal focus to be able to go
out and
and deal with uh coastal related issues
uh throughout the summer as well
i think that was all the questions thank
you councillor ashby
thank you leader um yes uh this is a
really welcome document and
congratulations to
um all the hard work and to the officers
that have put this together
um it's something that um i think has
been
sorely missed in the years that i've
certainly been
uh active on the beaches and the waters
of being a past
water user um
i'll just there's a couple of questions
um
we talk about signage but there there
was the old signs that used to
denote the ski lanes and the launching
sites and the way that you used to have
to ski round et cetera et cetera
and certainly embarrassed and i'm not
sure um
in uh sorry barnes is the barnes car
park site there used to be a big sign
that used to tell
everybody how they could launch where
they and which way around they used to
go
i know in 2019 the sign didn't appear
um and it was i don't know it was lost
or whatever but it's it's quite a large
sign which contains a lot of information
and um they they are really useful signs
and i think the one in beresford was
missing as well
so obviously last year it wasn't
necessarily an issue
um so hopefully they can be dug out and
put back up again the post is still
there um
the question on the fines can
the hundred pound fine that is mentioned
the collection of the fines i mean can
those finds be used i'm not sure where
they go into the d
crimp pot or what pot they go into but
are those fines can they be used
for additional recruitment of additional
enforcement officers
um also the um
the earlier draft that that we were
looking at um
on the the item is on on
the parking of camper vans it's a highly
contentious issue on this part
part of the world and i know right along
our coast where
a lot of people bring camper vans down
they camp out overnight
um the the original draft that i had did
include
overnight parking um restrictions on
overnight parking
um but i don't i'm not able to pick that
up i don't know if it's in a fuller
document
but the main question that i need to ask
is
um does the
does this restrict the parking of camper
vans and caravans on actual
seafront roadsides because it doesn't
make it very clear whether or not that
is included i
i get where it's in our car parks but
this is a massive issue and this does
cause a lot of fraction between
residents and uh visitors
and they do tend to spread out right
across some of the greens and
there's a lot of parties that go on late
at night and a lot of people that stay
in them overnight
um and it causes distress to a lot of
elderly residents that may live on their
own
um so you know is
is this included in the restriction
because we were led to believe that this
was the case so just some clarification
on that um the other section of um
driving on the promenade um always
around the time when the beach huts are
opening up
we the barriers get left open and we get
new
we get a lot of um beach hut owners that
come down drive along the prom to
deliver their
their um their stuff into their beach
hut um is that
still going to be a flexible facility or
is it going to be really restricted
because
it's always actually dragged on for
people tend to think that they they've
got this facility for
for about a month into the into the
season and
um there's quite a lot of traffic um if
people
all bring their cars down and deliver
people down there
um so is it are they going to be
prohibited from actually delivering
their stuff to their beach huts on this
new order
and the last thing uh are we going to
have a central number for contacting or
reporting
um a lot of people a lot of this
enforcement uh
or policing of this will be done by the
people themselves so i think we need to
take advantage of that
um certainly everybody loves to have a
moan i know but uh you know we
the eyes and ears can be from the actual
local
residents that can actually help us out
with this with a lot of this resource so
are we gonna have a central point to
contact our phone number
or not all people have got uh an iphone
on them where they can email but
certainly a number where they could at
least log a call
and then that could be transferred
through to the um
to the patrols um that's a sorry that's
a
that's a bit of a ramble a lot of
questions but to hopefully you've caught
all those jasmine so
or sting i don't know who's open
answering thank you thank thank you
councillor ashby i'll
i'll bring council album back in and i
suspect he's going to hand off some of
the answers but
counselor album uh well i i think what i
can
what i can definitely say uh counselor
ashby is that
um yes we are looking for uh to getting
a number that will be able for the
public to phone
uh it makes absolute sense
um and we should put that on our on our
signage
i think that's uh that's that's
important
um as for the um as for the
campervans et cetera i mean you and i
have had many a discussion about about
this at various places
uh certainly this pspo will count
on any um tensor exit
on our land we can't
take or serve the pspo on the highway
we would have to uh we would have to get
a traffic regulation order
as we have done in in various places
um but i i do take your
comments on that because i i just
happened to go along
palm bay yesterday and saw
several caravans there and i know
they've obviously been there a while so
they're using our parking areas for
putting their own personal
property on and not just park parking a
vehicle so i think that is something
that we should look at in relation to a
traffic regulation order
with kent county council and let's be
fair we have to go through
county council with that um
the barge car park signage uh whether
we've still got them or not
i don't know uh jasmine may be able to
answer that but it
it's a good point and it is something
that
maybe we should include on our signage
if if we haven't got these uh
these up these old ones um
driving on you know driving on the prom
for people to put their
um their gear for their for their beach
house i think if it
you know if it was a one-off thing i i
don't expect that we were going to take
any action
but however but as you said people going
down on a month i don't think we would
want that
because there is an issue with it i mean
if you've got several cars going down
at some time and the people are walking
along here that is an absolute safety
issue
so um jasmine may will have something to
uh
say in relation to that so
jasmine do you want to answer any
anything further
yes yeah i can come in and answer um
some more info on those questions
the barnes car park sign and the
beresford signs
some of our coastal signs are taken in
over the winter to protect them
otherwise they just don't survive the
elements
so i'll check with um with barry who
does all our signage
he's in the process of putting some of
it out at the moment so it might be that
it's in his store and it's and it's
going to get put back out again but
i will check up in case that was one
that that went missing for any reason
um the fines income we are interested in
the fined income but we're also
interested in generating income
through um some educational training
courses in relation to
uh litter and environmental impact and
and we're looking into some of those
schemes at the moment
because we do have the ability to offer
training courses as an aqa
accredited training provider now and
that is a potential source of income
that we could
use to fund more um support over the
summer season
we're not sure obviously on the amount
of fines that we're going to be
issuing out this year and it might be
that the majority of people comply with
what we're asking through the pspo
before we get to the point of issuing a
fine which is the ideal
scenario to be perfectly honest um
however yes
we can't um we haven't got an income
target on the fines or anything like
that because we really need to see how
it how it pans out this first season
um so that's that's something that we
can revisit
um the restrictions on the overnight
parking as councillor alban has said
um we would need a tra for that on the
on the on street um
which is something that we're looking at
at the moment for the particular areas
that we know
are a problem and i know in in westgate
there's particular issues and and
in ramsgate you know various locations
around the district
um we can
take action through the pspo if they are
using the green space because they often
park next to a green space and then
put an awning up or pitch tents have
barbecues have bonfires have parties or
whatever
we can take action over all of those
things um the issue really with using
the pspo for the on-street parking
element is
the we could give them the fixed penalty
notice for the
activity but we wouldn't be able to move
them on um
so the parking legislation is really the
most effective way of doing that
and that is something that we want to
push forward with
um in the coming in the next couple of
months to try and get some of those
pushed through
one of the problems we haven't done is
we don't have an overnight car park for
the camper vans
so there is a discussion potentially to
be had around
we're going to restrict the overnight
parking at all of these locations and we
identify
which ones they are around the coast but
we offer people
a particular car park for overnight
parking
so that that's something we have to you
know maybe look at
um driving on the proms leaving the
barriers open
it has been a big problem in recent
years because it allows
anyone then to come on and then access
our slipways and
all sorts of issues and it's a health
and safety problem um having that as
like a shared
space with cars and bikes and
pedestrians and dogs and all sorts of
things going on so
um yeah it is covered in the pspo uh we
are
restricting it the beach heart owners
and the beach hut
um customers will be given certain times
by your leisure
who manage all of their all of that
relationship to go down
into and to access the beach huts with
all of their equipment so they will get
the opportunities to do it
at set times um and as councillor auburn
said we're not going to be finding
individual people
you know we are going to ask them not to
do it and and to stop doing it
if we catch them in the act but if it's
a persistent problem in a location we
you know we might have to have somebody
down there monitoring it
um central number for contacting
um we're gonna have two single points of
contact two numbers that can be called
um directly and the beaches at
family.gov dot uk will be the
email address for all email inquiries
and we will get that put on the signs as
well
i think that was it thank you
thank you well uh other members of
cabinet has anybody got any comments or
questions they wish to raise
i'm not seeing any so um the um
recommendations has been moved and
seconded is that agreed members does i
hear any objection i'll take that as
agreed
that's agreed thank you so we move on to
item five which is the dog public spaces
protection order remembrance
counselor album
here we go again um tdc
extended the existing of pspo
until the 25th of october 2023
which covers dog fouling dog exclusion
and dog control the existing order
has helped protect the diversity of the
bird population and wildlife
of peg wall bay upper chalk
short mud flats and salt marches
the order has protected the quality
of the public health and welfare through
enforcement which is seen
sorry which has been helping promote
cleaner beaches
parks churchyards and fenced play areas
the amended pspo will mostly be the same
as that
which has been in force for the last
three years
but with the addition of amendments
of two amendments to help uh
protect coastal wildlife these changes
were proposed
for consultation as a request
for consideration from the public and
other stakeholders the
recommendation is that the current pspo
is altered to support minor amendments
until 2023
um both refer to coastal wildlife
and are one peg wall bay
amend to cover upperchalk short
to protect endangered wildlife and
feedback has been positive on this
amendment
two activities
that could be banned to protect wildlife
a human and dogs interfering with
trapping or attempting to trap or snare
or disturb
any wildlife on council-owned land
and again feedback has been positive
the third proposed amendment regarding
westbrook bay
the public responded in the majority
for no change and i'm not proposing any
change to take place on west
brook beach and i propose cabinet agree
option one as defined in 3.1
of the report thank you councillor alban
i'll second that
um any discussion members
no so unless i hear any objection i'll
take that as approved
that's agreed thank you and we move on
to item six which is the new open spaces
grass cutting regime
for pollinators and that's council album
as well
aren't you all lucky this evening um in
my dulcet tones
um the pollinators such as bees
butterflies and moths
are vital to our environment ecology
and our food however as we all know
they are in serious decline
the most significant significant
cause of pollinator decline
and one that tdc open spaces
can immediately address is the loss
and degradation of their habitats
the climate change officer and open
spaces team
have taken advice from the bumblebee
trust and plant life uk
on how to address this problem
following this advice we are proposing
to reduce
grass cutting on selected areas
of large open spaces such as along the
coast
to create native wildflower meadows
no cutting between april and september
we will be we will cut a walkway
through the middle of these areas to
allow easy access
and the surrounding areas will also be
cut
to define the area signage will
also be displayed and we will also be
taking part
in the no mo may
in our parks to help smaller flowers
grow to enable our pollinators to feed
the specific areas are listed within the
report
and shown in maps which are added as
appendices
members are fully aware of the climate
emergency motion
approved by council in 2019
and this proposed action goes hand in
hand
with that motion uh i therefore
propose cabinet approve the report as in
the recommendations which are
to change the cutting regime with
monitoring of public perception
and feedback and two delegate authority
to the director of operations in
consultation
with the cabinet member for operational
services
to approve minor amendments to the
policy
thank you chair uh thank you councillor
alban i'll second that
and we've got councillor ghana to speak
on this item
thank you yeah i'd just like to welcome
this new open spaces grass cutting
regime
and would like to thank um the climate
change officer
and all those involved in putting
putting it together
as someone who volunteered as part of
the buzz for the coast project
i recognize the importance of improving
the habitat for pollinators
and other wildlife across planet and
believe this is a really good step
forward
to ensure its success this summer and
over years to come
it will be important for us to engage
with the wider community
particularly in the areas where changes
will be noticeable
to make sure that the positive benefits
to the wider environment
of the new regime are understood i know
the communications team
have put together a plan to publicize
this over the coming weeks and months
which will i'm sure extol the positive
benefits to the what
of the wider environment of the new
regime
and encourage as many of those residents
as possible
fortunate to have their own garden to
think about how they could change their
own grass-cutting routines
would it be possible just to hear a
little bit more about
this communication plan and also maybe
consider
as lockdown restrictions start to ease
ways in which we can bring community
groups together
to get involved in planting projects in
parks around the district
especially for those residents without
gardens
thank you thank you councillor council
album
yeah thank you yeah i i
support your view cancer ghana um
i i have already uh spoken with our
parks uh manager uh actually last year
before lockdown when we were um we went
around various parks
and one of the things that i was would
like to actually do
as you quite rightly say is to get
communities involved
um trying to get some community groups
going in relation to our parks
and um but also to get schools involved
to see whether we can get
uh children involved which is very very
important
um and so yeah i take your view um i'm
sure
um our comms team will will be more than
happy to
uh brief you uh once that's gone out and
to keep you informed of that count
councilor ghana
thank you thank you councillor album um
members any comments on this
i mean i'd just like to to give it my
support i think it's um
i think it's a very positive initiative
and i do i do agree that communicating
why we're doing what we're doing to the
public
will be key to its success but i think
there'll be a lot of support for in the
community
right members so unless i hear any
objection i'm going to take this is
approved
so that is approved thank you and that
concludes the business for tonight so i
declare the meeting closed
i think it's about 6 15. thanks to
everyone who participates